hey youtubers is Charlie so this week
for my bonus arrow and flash video I
wanted to talk about my top ten favorite
characters I'm gonna exclude Oliver and
most of team arrow because they were
just hog like half the list and there's
a bunch of other characters that deserve
to be mentioned I am still catching up
after being gone for a couple days so
instead of doing a separate flash video
I'm just gonna include an update about
you know some new things that we learned
in this video so if you're finding me
for the first time I do Marvel and DC
videos every week be sure to subscribe
to get everything and feel free to leave
me suggestions for bonus video topics so
before we do arrow real quick let's do
that flash update the big news is is
that producers confirmed John Wesley
Shipp was playing Barry Allen's father
Harry Allen he's gonna be in several
episodes in the comics his character
dies in prison so either the show is
just gonna use him in a lot of
flashbacks or they're gonna change the
comics story so that he can be alive in
present-day either way it's confirmed so
now let's talk about our favorite arrow
characters this season starting with
number 10 dr. Ivo such a huge villain
from the comics I got really excited
when I heard he was gonna be on the show
they opted to dial him way back from his
comic book persona and make it more of a
tragic villain at the end of his rope
they did humanize him eventually
you know teasing his daughter and his
wife but the biggest Easter Egg was the
Amazo boat Amazo for those who don't
know is an Android from DC Comics he's a
Justice League villain who's kind of
like an analogue of Marvel's Ultron
Amazo can mimic anyone's power so think
of like the future Sentinels from Days
of Future past the ones that just mimic
other people's powers I was a little
disappointed that they didn't tease you
know the Amazo Android but because
season 2 was all about this mirakuru
plot I understand why they dialed those
things back everyone also started kind
of wondering whether he was secretly
Felicity's father I think given what the
producers have said and the things that
went down that is not the case and
Felicity's dad is gonna turn out to be
someone even cooler and more to those
comic book Easter eggs it's totally
possible that a book could have been
working on other research that we just
did not see on-screen the way I think
about comic book stuff is like this if
you do not see it on the show and none
of the actors and producers ever talked
about it there's still a chance that it
could happen in the future
so we could totally see an Android
somewhere down the line
but until a producer or someone behind
the show says absolutely not it's still
a possibility it's still floating around
somewhere in an imaginary closet number
nine Sebastian blood as brother blood
from the comics came and all the hundred
k m-- into his own the second half of
the season they did turn a lot of the
demonic aspects of the character from
the comics into metaphorical ones and
brother blood revealed that he wore that
mask is a way to have conquered demons
so it was a slight homage to some of the
origins in the comics on the show I felt
like his character became more of an
analogue for the Scarecrow in the Dark
Knight trilogy you know a scientist with
a formula before he learned all the
details about the mirakuru I actually
thought the League of Assassins was
helping him with it just because of the
fear toxin from Batman Begins a lot of
you guys also ask me whether or not I
thought he survived those stab wounds
from Isabel at the end of the season and
I'll say it again you know unless we see
a severed head or the producers confirm
he's dead he can totally come back just
think comic book logic number eight
Malcolm Merlyn I think the real crime on
arrow this year was that John Barrowman
did not get more episodes and based on
what's gonna be happening in season 3 it
sounds like the writers agreed John
Barrowman was upgraded to cast regular
for season 3 meeting he's gonna be in
most of the episodes like more than half
of them which is 12 or 13 even though he
only got to appear a handful of times
since season 2 he's one of the most
memorable actors playing one of the most
memorable Green Arrow villains he's
essentially meant to be a foil for
Oliver like the darkest timeline version
of Oliver that's why whenever we start
talking more about Oliver's journey in
season 3 we'll be able to start figuring
out some of what Merlyn is gonna be
doing one of my biggest predictions for
season 3 is that Oliver is going into
rebuilding mode and he's just going to
be focusing on the core team arrow
Stephen Amell even said that Oliver and
Laurel haven't really addressed the big
WTF secret identity in the room yet so
that makes me think she's not gonna
formally become a member of team arrow
at least till later in the season so all
that just means that Merlyn is probably
going to be in rebuilding mode too and
Thea is just going to be the first new
member of his team somatically I always
liked it better when each character has
an opposite like Oliver and Malcolm I
think we can call fiha
Roy's new
I'm sure he's gonna be really happy to
learn about that number seven sin how
can you not love Roy and sin during the
second half of the season I was really
bummed she didn't get more episodes and
she was kind of kept out of the loop on
everything she didn't know anything
about the mirakuru Sarah never told her
about the League of Assassins and they
never really addressed what her
character would be doing what she was on
her own again it was only implied but I
think eventually we'll see her helping
Roy with missions in season 3 plus
there's always the possibility of Young
Justice spin-off she could totally
become part of that if it ever happens I
would say my favorite sin moment was
when she and Roy tried to fight crime
together that was hilarious number 6 Roy
as Arsenal my opinion of his character
did a major 180 from the beginning of
the season to the end that's just the
magic of a character arc Laurel was Alma
too but I liked Roy's more almost
homeless dude gets injected with super
serum overcomes it becomes a member of
mini Justice League team if only it were
that simple in real life
my favorite Roy moments were training
with Oliver and when he was first trying
to figure out his powers after episode
10 getting that montage of heroes
playing with their powers right after
they get them is so much fun and I think
we're gonna get that in the flash number
5 Nyssa al Ghul one of the best new
female characters on the show she was a
Master Assassin they could match Oliver
in a fight had the might of Rochelle
Ghul at her back and in an interesting
twist was one of the only LGBTQ
characters this season she was so
awesome there is no way the show is not
bringing her back my favorite Nyssa
moment was actually a funny one it was
when she had that standoff moment with
felicity at the end of the season it
almost looked like she was looking at
felicity as a sex object like she was
sexually attracted to her while she was
sizing her up tumblr I am gonna test you
with making that reaction jiff number 4
Sara Lance as the canary
Caity Lotz had the hard task of stepping
in between Laurel and Oliver as a
romantic foil but I got so excited when
I saw her as the canary for the first
time it took the first half of the
season to figure out where her character
was headed and yes I do wish she could
have spent more time teaming up with
Oliver on missions but I also like the
way she interacted with some of the rest
of the team she had this really funny
relationship with Felicity that went
from distrust all the way
to a mutual respect by the end there was
a brief moment when I thought she was
going to out Felicity felicity button
spoiler alert that's impossible there is
only one quirky tech genius on Team
arrow and she went to MIT Sara could
always come back on the show as part of
a League of Assassins story or as part
of a Laurel story but for the most part
I think that she's off the show I'm
really happy that they did leave the
characters exit very open-ended isn't
she did not die but passing that Black
Canary jacket on to Laurel is just heavy
foreshadowing number three Amanda Waller
hands-down biggest new non villain
badass on the show I say non villain but
she's really a neutral figure in the DC
Universe she serves the government
ultimately so sometimes it takes her
against super heroes like Oliver she
tied up a few big plots from season one
and created a whole bunch of new ones
during season two that will inform all
of those Hong Kong flashbacks in season
three she's like one of those Halo
characters that the show will probably
never kill just because they're way too
interesting Stephen Amell also confirmed
one of our biggest theories Amanda
Waller was in fact the woman with the
red shoes behind the hole Edward Fyers
Chyna plot in case you forgot they were
trying to decimate China's economy which
kind of explains why she was in Hong
Kong one of the biggest things that I'm
looking forward to in season 3 though is
the Hong Kong flashbacks telling the
history of Amanda Waller and Oliver's
relationship number 2 Barry Allen never
has a new character so naturally become
a member of team arrow
since Felicity Smoak just talking about
the character first Barry was the
perfect call to action for Oliver in the
first half of the season
he's the one that gave him that green
arrow mask like he helped Oliver make a
giant leap forward in his hero's journey
obviously there's all the spin-off stuff
going off to the side The CW is actually
commented that after the pilot episode
they feel like the flash is their
strongest new show in the last 10 years
you know next to arrow there's a lot of
reasons for that
but having a very fun and positively
character like Barry on makes it a lot
easier to shoot a show that people can
get really excited about
I thought Grant Gustin was amazing as
Barry Allen I didn't have a lot of
preconceived notions but the only thing
I've seen him do before this was Bianca
Lee and he was kind
antagonist on that show I don't see a
lot of villain inside Barry Allen but
I'm interested to see how he uses his
experience playing an antagonist to add
some complexity to the character I think
I've been being more of a tortured
person but if we're comparing grumpy
superheroes Oliver would win every time
hands down
Barry is like this hyperactive superhero
fanboy so if you actually just look at
the way they shot the flash trailer
everything's in like bright daylight as
opposed to like the really dark noir
scenes that you see in the Gotham TV
show and on arrow so the flash is gonna
be a much more positive show based on
that and my number one arrow character
in season 2 Deathstroke Manu Bennett is
just an amazing actor and had two full
years to develop his Slade Wilson
character the Deathstroke persona didn't
really develop until season 2 and even
then it really didn't manifest until
halfway through the season he's gonna go
down as one of the best villains in any
DC show which creates some interesting
problems for season 3
I'm actually really hoping that the show
uses him is like a Hannibal Lecter
character next season like Oliver it
goes to him for advice on whoever the
new villain is I actually asked you guys
to submit your fan art of Slade as
Hannibal so high fives to summit Shetty
for submitting this fan art of Slade as
Hannibal very very cool I will probably
be doing more fan art submissions for
other shows in the future for anyone
who's interested but I realized I had to
leave a ton of awesome characters off
the list so now it's your turn let me
know in the comments who was your
favorite character in season 2 and what
was your favorite scene from them I'm
still catching up after being out of
town for four days but tomorrow I'm
still doing my regular arrow and flash
Q&A and a Maleficent review if I can see
it early enough be sure to subscribe to
get everything if I don't get to
Maleficent Thursday night then that
second video is there gonna be Marvel or
Star Wars that I just had to skip on
Tuesday but I'm definitely doing
Maleficent before the weekend so right
now click here to learn more about arrow
season 3 and the flash season 1 and
click here for my x-men Days of Future
Passed review thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tomorrow
high fives